ooh I just noticed this I don't of you
knows it too but here's some BuzzFeed
lists I saw recently check this one out
11 dolphins that are only smiling
because they're peeing now that's just
that's not a good list No then this one
7 jeopardy champions who slept with
Watson I mean oh boy where's that oh but
look at this 12 guys who absolutely in
no way shape or form look like William H
may see look at the 17 koalas with whom
you do not want to get into a debate
about gay marriage trust us and a gay
good day 31 photos of Dwayne the rock
Johnson with a tiny head okay you know
what that's a good one
I was wrong BuzzFeed's not running out
of this look at this one 13 cars that
really don't need that denim pocket
there's this one 21 high-speed photos
where you can actually see Trump advisor
Stephen Miller catch a fly with his
tongue here's one 36 animals where you
just know God was phoning it in why do I
like that one that they an audience know
here we go check this list out pick a
Confederate statue and will tell you
which Hello Kitty backpack you are stand
finally 32 litter box clumps that look
like characters from friends I worried
are worried that they're running out of
lists
you